[Musique]
paris 11h30 patrouille de routine au
plus tard regarde moi ça me giraud
[Musique]
monsieur vous pouvez le contacter s'il
vous plaît c'est pour quand vous êtes
monsieur je voulais trop vite non c'est
pas notre problème ça ça va un
autocollant l'arrière du véhicule
monsieur annoncé pas marrant c'est une
blague des années 80 c'est toujours une
ses impôts est en fait une âpre et et ce
avant ça va pour cette fois
la prochaine fois ce sont 90 euros
damende ces cas d'accord elle circulait
merci monsieur l'agent journey monsieur
les gens
[Musique]
j'ai pas toujours voulu de gdh mais un
jour je me baladais dans la rue je suis
passé devant un salon de coiffure et
c'est quand j'ai vu le nom de la
boutique que je me suis dit là faire
quelque chose quoi pas de répit pour les
agents qui sont à nouveau sollicités
cette fois ci pour une intervention à
domicile il a plu je me suis plu chez
dans les plumes de perroquet dit ça se
calme on vous prévient on a l'habitude
de ce genre d'intervention là c'est
madame qui a appelé mais c'est souvent
les voisins aussi canton des blagues à
travers les murs
donc là on va aux dés h2i c'est un
service qui surveille les réseaux
sociaux en permanence et qui essaie
d'identifier les modèles d'infractions
qui se répète savard écharpe le problème
sur internet c'est que avec l'anonymat
les gens ils se permettent tout donc
cbsp des ssd
c'est apparemment je vais vous lire un
tweet ta meuf a pris du poids avant tu
te faisais un ton maintenant elle fait
une tonne voilà dix est signée rémy
figue mi raisin je pourrais le chercher
dans la base de données mais je pense je
sais pas son vrai nom
à peine reparti les agents sont alertés
par un groupe de jeunes a choisi leur
camp
alors évidemment c'est de pas trop juger
sur le faciès mais là par expérience vu
leurs dégaines ça ça veut dire problème
bonjour à savoir ce que vous faites on
discute à vous discutez de quoi rien ah
bon papier de carambar là c'est quoi
pas moi c'est pas toi alors pourquoi tu
l'as tuée quand je suis arrivé c'est pas
un crime mais manger 10 carats mais en
tout cas le ton dix minutes on revient
vous au plus là c'est clair encore une
journée bien remplie pour la police de
l'humour c'est avec le sentiment du
devoir accompli
on s'autorise enfin à se détendre et
demain il faudra recommencer car jamais
rien et paisible pour qui veut maintenir
la presse
[Musique]